it's taken almost a week for some people
to get their first supplies of food and
clean water
aid shipments are now arriving by the
plane load it's not enough
but it is a start if you ask people down
there they're seeing a flow
a flow of goods and that's what's
important and not again not just the
tacloban but out to
you know a couple dozen outlying far
distant areas that that might not
otherwise have gotten assistance on the
return legs the planes ferry people out
mainly children and the injured away
from the devastation to comparative
safety
from the air residents see for the first
time the full extent of the destruction
in tacloban itself people are clearing
debris from the streets
this city of 200 000 is a field of
rubble
heavy equipment has been brought in and
it's finding more and more corpses
we have to deal with sensitivities of uh
people here because there are still some
categories
uh lying on the sidewalk so we have to
be
sure that we won't be touching the
bodies
it will still be some time before we
know how many people the typhoon killed